Коли нас питають: «Як твої?»,
ти не знаєш, що відповісти.
Тому що твої — це всі.
Кожен українець і українка —
це зараз мої сестра і брат.
Тому це все зараз — ми.
І ми так само переживаємо
як за наших,
так і за не рідних людей,
але ми всі зараз разом і
всі працюємо на одну мету.
Ми працюємо
в двох напрямках.
Це переважно гуманітарна
допомога в Україну,
і на це збираються
великі кошти.
Другий напрямок —
це допомога на місцях,
допомога біженцям.
Бо зараз в Німеччину вже
багато людей приїхало.
Дуже багато німців,
дуже багато українців,
які тут вже довго живуть,
вони запропонували безкоштовно
свої оселі, свої кімнати.
За 13 років в Німеччині я стільки
відкритих і добрих людей
ще не зустрічала сконцентрованих
в одному місці.
Це дуже приємно,
що люди організовуються
в такий важкий час разом.
«Синьо-жовтий хрест»
створили ми 2017 року,
німецькою мовою це називається
«Blau-gelbes Kreuz».
І 2016-го, 2017-го,
2018-го і 2019 року ми
запрошували дітей,
дітей наших
загиблих героїв
або дітей, котрі в Маріуполі
тоді обстріляні були,
також самі постраждали,
на два тижні без війни.
З 24 лютого 2022 року в
нас змінилося завдання.
Як усі українці
по цілому світу,
ми допомагаємо Україні,
українцям.
Ми допомагаємо
цьому демократичному
вільному руху
наших українців.
В цих боксах — медикаменти
за спеціальним списком,
встановленим нашими колегами,
лікарями в Німеччині.
Вони містять приблизно
130 різних медичних продуктів
і медикаментів, якими можна
забезпечити приблизно 100 пацієнтів
в 90 % усіх критичних випадків,
які можуть статися на війні.
Ми так само співпрацюємо
з організацією пілотів,
які допомагають нам відправляти
життєво важливі медикаменти,
які повинні бути
доставлені швидко.
До них належать,
наприклад, інсуліни
або інші медикаменти,
які потрібно охолоджувати.
Там рахунок йде на години.
Відповідно, для нас так само
важливо не просто доставляти,
але доставляти це швидко і
доставляти це куди найнеобхідніше.
Цього тижня ми отримали
запит від багатьох лікарень,
що конче необхідні
діагностичні набори
для жертв зґвалтування.
Це спеціальні тести для того,
щоб підтвердити
факт зґвалтування жінок.
Не тільки молодих жінок, але
й дітей, і навіть вагітних жінок.
[німецькою] Дякую вам,
можна вас трохи потурбувати?
[німецькою] Дуже дякую.
До нас привозять гігієнічні засоби,
харчування для дітей.
Або харчування,
або медикаменти.
Ми їх розпаковуємо,
тут сортуємо
і потім ставимо на палету,
підготовлюємо до того,
щоб надіслати
потім вантажівкою в Україну.
Кожного дня йде мінімум
одна вантажівка і
декілька маленьких або
великих приватних авто.
Мене звуть Діана, я
з Донецької області,
з маленького міста
Костянтинівка,
що якраз на трасі,
воно є останнім містом
перед Донецьком,
60 км від нього.
Мені 18 років, зараз я
в Кельні як студентка.
Я тут уже півтора роки.
Це місце, це об'єднання,
ця організація —
це те, що допомагає
мені жити,
тому що, якщо
б цього не було,
я не знаю, що
було б зі мною.
Оце ось просто сидіти
вдома та розуміти,
що ти взагалі нічого
не можеш зробити...
Перші чотири дні війни я
якраз це і робила:
сиділа вдома та тільки читала,
читала, читала новини.
24/7, завжди.
А потім якось побачила,
що тут є ця організація,
що можна
прийти допомогти.
Ми працюємо на складі,
ми сортуємо речі,
котрі нам привозять як
приватні пожертвування.
Нам дуже важливо розсортувати
ці речі по коробках.
Наприклад, у нас є різні
місця для гелів для душу,
для шампунів, для
усілякого цього.
І це наша
найголовніша задача.
У нас є окрема зона для
гігієни та для медицини,
також засоби
якісь для кемпінгу,
наприклад, запальнички,
свічки, щось таке.
І потім далі ми
сортуємо вже їжу.
Я можу сказати, що тут
зараз допомагають
найбільше саме
українці та німці.
Є багато дуже
добрих людей,
які дійсно
співчувають цьому.
Які також не розуміють,
як це могло статися,
що в Європі почалась
настільки кривава,
настільки жахлива війна.
Ось, наприклад,
я можу сказати,
що з тих, хто
зараз тут перебуває,
можливо, тільки п'ять людей
з 15-ти — це українці,
всі інші — німці.
[німецькою]
Мене звати Алекс.
[німецькою] Я заповнюю
документи для митниці.
[німецькою] Слідкую, щоб
транспорт, який ми тут завантажуємо,
[німецькою]
дістався України.
[німецькою] І щоб цей процес був
максимально безперешкодний.
[німецькою] Крім того, я
організовую нам вантажівки
[німецькою] і контролюю, що
надходить до складу, а що виїжджає.
[німецькою] Ми всі знаємо,
який страшний злочин
[німецькою]
там [в Україні] відбувається.
[німецькою] Дивлячись лише на фото
за останні дні з околиць Києва.
[німецькою]
Ми всі були дуже шоковані.
[німецькою] Нас об'єднує
бажання підтримувати Україну,
[німецькою] адже ми бачимо, що вона
бореться за свободу і демократію.
[німецькою] Вона бореться
проти фашизму. І це нас об'єднує.
[німецькою] Я вважаю, що
дуже важливо допомагати людям.
[німецькою] З початку війни
я хотів активно допомагати
[німецькою] і шукав
таких можливостей у Кельні.
[німецькою] Так я знайшов
організацію «Синьо-жовтий хрест».
[німецькою] І мені відразу було дуже
приємно співпрацювати з цими людьми
[німецькою] і в тому числі
з біженцями з України.
[німецькою] Я думаю, що ця війна
змінить наше суспільство,
[німецькою]
бо зараз іде війна в Європі.
[німецькою] Війни відбуваються
по всьому світу, але коли війна
[німецькою]
на порозі твого дому,
[німецькою] то люди
більше звертають на це увагу.
[німецькою] І сподіваюся,
що це ще більше змотивує
[німецькою]
людей допомагати.
[німецькою] Слава Богу, рівень
допомоги уже дуже високий.
Зараз тут ми передаємо
багато інформації
і ми її висвітлюємо
різними методами:
ми робимо протестну ходу,
мітинги солідарності.
На 30-річчя Незалежності України
ми робили велике свято.
Ми робили святкову ходу в місті Кельн
із 100-метровим прапором.
І після цього наша громада
дуже виросла,
бо люди зрозуміли: «О, в Кельні
є стільки багато українців.
Давайте єднатися!»
Зараз, під час війни, ці люди
також одразу активізувалися, і
ми робимо такі самі
мітинги та демонстрації,
показуючи місцевому населенню,
скільки є тут уже на підтримку.
Це не лише українці.
Також багато німців
приходить на наші демонстрації,
підтримують нас.
[німецькою]
З одного боку, ми повинні
[німецькою] щоразу показувати нашу
солідарність з нашими друзями,
[німецькою] показувати,
що ми їх не забуваємо.
[німецькою] Що ми не будемо
терпіти російських автопробігів.
[німецькою] І наша відповідь
буде ще сильнішою.
[німецькою] Саме тому ми дуже вдячні,
навіть попри такий трагічний привід,
[німецькою] що і тут, на цій площі,
щоразу збирається багато людей,
[німецькою]
щоб подати чіткий сигнал.
[німецькою] Передусім також нашим
братам і сестрам з України,
[німецькою] які побачать
ці кадри, що надихатимуть
[німецькою]
і мотивуватимуть їх ще більше,
[німецькою] будуть додавати сили
після цих жахливих шести тижнів,
[німецькою] а точніше,
жахливих восьми років.
[німецькою] Українці, ми з вами!
Сьогоднішня демонстрація
відбувається в місті Кельн
біля кельнського собору.
Тут ви бачите
позаду свічки —
це символ всіх вбитих
українців росіянами.
Ці демонстрації дуже важливі,
тому що Україна потребує
максимально німецької підтримки.
Зараз.
Тут.
Через санкції, через заборону
німецького бізнесу в Росії,
через максимальну підтримку
України всіма можливими
і потрібними способами,
які пришвидшать
українську перемогу.
[німецькою] Ми маємо
допомагати Україні.
[німецькою]
Вони наші друзі.
[німецькою] Наша організація
надає гуманітарну допомогу.
[німецькою] І ми робимо це,
наскільки це можливо.
[німецькою] Але наш уряд
мав би визнати це вторгнення
[німецькою] передумовою для
втручання НАТО
[німецькою] і разом з усіма
членами НАТО стати
[німецькою]
на захист України,
[німецькою] аби якомога швидше
вигнати росіян з її території.
Я впевнена, що
українське суспільство
стане сильнішим,
і як нація
ми нарешті об’єднаємося
у всіх можливих сенсах.
Авжеж, буде ще час змін, але те,
що ми зараз бачимо,
навіть в діаспорі тут, в Німеччині,
ми бачимо ці кроки,
які люди роблять
задля однієї ідеї.
Багато хто з людей нарешті,
наприклад,
перейшли на українську мову.
Я — одна з них.
Зброю, яку ми маємо, —
це слово, це діло.
Якщо у нас опустяться руки,
значить, у нашого фронту
не буде тилу.
Тому кожного дня ми розуміємо,
що руки опускати не можна.
Треба, авжеж, давати собі, як людині,
знижку на те, що треба перепочити.
Якщо ви волонтер — обов’язково
давайте собі можливість видихнути,
встати наступного ранку і
далі продовжувати.
Але опускати руки не можна.
Тепер у нас є шанс вистояти.
Ми вистоїмо.
Світ буде кращим,
я впевнена.
Ми відбудуємо нашу Україну і
цю націю ніхто більше не забуде.
І не забудуть, як важливо
шанувати свободу і демократію.
І світ буде кращим, я впевнена.
Віримо в це!
Україна — це мій дім.
Це є я.
Навіть коли я в Німеччині,
я ношу з собою частину України,
і кожен із нас є частиною України.
І цей весь наш табір,
наша організація —
це маленька Україна, і
ми всі разом, ми спільнота.
Я ніколи про це не думала,
проте зараз я стала
дуже патріотичною людиною.
І зараз я тільки хочу повернутися
додому та побачити свою матір.